[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ramsey personality number one
best-selling author christy wright is my
co-host today as we talk to you about
your life and your money her new book
soon to be a number one bestseller is
called take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance and
it is available on pre-sale now it will
come out september the 14th and she and
i will be doing a live stream event on
september the 16th on the same subject
so if you want to talk about life
balance you want to talk about money you
want to talk about anything we are here
for you the phone number again triple
eight eight two five five two two five
lavelle starts us off in raleigh north
carolina hi lavelle how are you
i'm doing great how about yourself
better than i deserve what's up
oh um i had a question for my uh car um
that i purchased and i wanted to
um didn't know if i should sell it or if
i should
uh just just keep going just keep going
with it until it's paid off
when did you purchase it
um so i purchased it probably about four
or five four to five months ago okay and
what do you owe on it
um i owe 18 000. what's your household
income
uh 45
45 000. are you married
no i'm not single okay is that your only
vehicle
yes sir it is how much other debt do you
have other than your house
um i have about
seven thousand left in student loan debt
and um a thousand uh dollars left at the
credit at my credit union for our
personal loan okay
well christy here's the principle that
we always use on this okay a car lavelle
is the largest thing we all buy
that goes down in value
another way of saying that it is the
largest wealth destructor
in our lives it destroys more of our
wealth than anything else does that make
sense
yes sir because it's the most expensive
thing we buy that goes down in value i
mean if you buy a thousand dollar tv and
four years later throw it in the
backyard no big deal it didn't change
your life but when you take a 25 000 car
or 20 000 car
and turn it into a 6 000 car which is
what they always do right
then you have destroyed a lot of wealth
per dollars wise does that make sense
yes sir and yet we all love cars i got
cars i'm a car guy i want you to have i
don't want everybody to drive a junker
the rest of their lives but you need to
understand that ratio wise the more crap
you own that goes down in value the
harder it's going to be to become
wealthy
so based on that idea
the principle that we developed or the
concepts that we developed are two
number one can you be
100 debt-free not counting your house
inside of two years and keep the car
this is assuming you love the car and
are willing to fight scratch and claw to
keep the stupid thing do you do you
lavell do you love it
um i actually don't i actually have a
buyer for it um that that wants to buy
it next week i've put it on the auto
trader and why did you put it on auto
trader
um
because i wanted to i wanted to get out
of i wanted to get out of bed and maybe
get a cheaper car maybe pay cash for a
car and go through my
um credit union okay and possibly get
the loan to pay off the difference and
you know maybe get a little extra to you
know two or three thousand extra to pay
the car okay good i need to get his cash
car yeah get you a cash car okay that's
a plan go do that go do that i think
you've got i think you've got a great
plan i don't want to stop you from doing
your plan
it's a plan that i probably would do if
i woke up in your shoes let me finish
giving you the principles for the rest
of our listeners sake and because you
might apply them at some other
point
okay
number one we have to be debt-free
inside of two years or the car has to go
you could pull that off it'd be a lot of
hard work but you can pull that off you
got 26 thousand dollars in debt you make
40 you could work an extra job live on
beans and rice rice and beans and be
debt-free in two years it could be done
okay but you're not going to i
understand but i'm just saying
mathematically that's doable the second
thing is
is the is all the things that you own
with wheels and motors because
everything with wheels and motors goes
down in value
and again i've got a lot of stuff with
wheels and motors i'm not against having
it i'm just against it having you
i'm against you being owned by this crap
they all go down in value and when you
add them all up do they equal more than
half
your annual income
if they do you have too much juice tied
up in things that are destroying your
wealth instead of building your wealth
and so you know people call me up i'm
making seventy five thousand dollars a
year i got a fifty thousand dollar truck
well you might be a redneck if
you know that's just that's just stupid
and that principle applies whether it's
uh paid for even if it's paid for is
that what you're saying exactly yeah
you see level you got things you know a
50 000 truck is going to be worth 25
about 20 seconds
about 20 seconds i mean it doesn't take
long at all no no one thinks about that
about the fact that the car i like how
you just said that
cars are the most expensive things we
buy that go down in value i mean like
when you say you're like yeah that makes
sense but no one looks at cars that way
they look at it like hey i got a raise
let me go get a bigger car they don't
look at it as this thing that is two
steps forward three steps back when it
comes to building wealth and i think
that's important i like that you pointed
that out yeah when you when you
put 50 000 in the middle of the table
and over a series of
four years you burn most of it with a
match yeah that's a problem yeah it's
just for unless you unless you make 150
000 then you can survive that but it's
still a problem i mean i own cars that
are expensive today yeah but just for
the used cars i mean just for the new
car smell that lasts about a month go
get you some air freshener
yeah like losing that amount of money
for a new car for that very
short-term feeling
when it drops i mean gosh that just it
drops so quickly in value and tom
stanley discovered this the first time i
read it was in 1992.
uh he wrote the book the millionaire
next door
and he one of the things he discovered
in his research of millionaires which we
have done our own research these days
but
and that was the first time i ever heard
it was the typical millionaire drives a
two-year-old or older car because i had
this thing that rich people all drive
nice cars
and the truth is that a certain level of
rich does right but until you've got a
million dollars in net worth buying a
brand new car is mathematically stupid
yeah now you can do it and get away with
it but it's just stupid well even after
you have a million dollars net worth you
still look at cars differently because
the principles that got you to that net
worth or the principles you want to
maintain not to your point not that you
can't get a new car but you're going hey
i could get one that's two years old
it's depreciated 50 of its value and i'm
going to maintain the value longer yeah
like i said i got i got several vehicles
with boats and sea doos and
you know side by side on the farm and i
i'm i collect i'm yeah i'm like a
grown-up boy you know i collect things
that go wood and wooden you know i mean
and so but but when i i'm constantly
running that factor and going
all of these things added together need
to be a very small percentage
of my world because they're all just
sitting here rusting down to nothing
yeah money-wise meanwhile i could have
taken the same money and put in
something goes up in value which would
give me more to give
and more to do with yeah
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and serving christian
health cost sharing ministry chm has
shared medical expenses for its members
since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five most people make choices
based on feelings or opinions especially
when they're buying a house but when it
comes to a real estate market feelings
are not your friends
facts are your friends
you got to get people in your corner
help you with the facts because it gets
really emotional when you're selling a
home buying a home and when you're doing
it in some of these markets right now
that are absolutely white hot it's crazy
out there
it is not amateur hour you don't want to
get somebody in your corner that sold
two houses and that and you're their
third transaction
good lord
this is your most expensive asset get a
pro in your corner we vet our
ramsey trusted endorsed local providers
to be some of the top agents high octane
high protein in your area you can find
the ones that
we recommend
and ramsey solutions dot com slash agent
ramsey solutions dot com
slash
agent jonathan is with us in coeur
d'alene idaho hi jonathan welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave hey what's up
well um unfortunately my uncle passed
away earlier this week oh
my sorry i'm a little nervous here it's
okay i'm sorry to hear that were you
close yeah
yeah i was feeling like a dad to me
oh man
going through his paperwork and his will
it looks like he left me
quite a bit in his estate um
total amount looks like it's probably
going to be over half a million dollars
not exactly sure what to do with it
in cash or in what
uh real estate a home that's worth about
400 that he owned outright and then the
rest is i haven't figured out exactly
how much it is but it's at least a
hundred thousand in checking account a
pension
and another retirement account
what do you make a year
uh about 65. how old are you
33. okay you ever handled anything like
an estate before
i had with my mom but it was uh
valued at probably about a hundred
thousand so it's obviously a lot less
than this okay
so are you uh you found the will then
yes okay so you've been appointed the
executor of the estate
correct and you are the only heir
correct okay
so my advice first would be to contact a
good estate
probate attorney to probate the will and
get you put in charge of each of these
accounts as soon as possible by the
court
okay and we actually did start the
process on that but we still have to
wait for the death certificate
unfortunately it takes a little time but
i'm glad to know you're already doing
that good okay and uh well
the emotion is real
and obviously you know you guys were
close he was like a dad to you and he
was obviously loved you a lot he left
you everything
and so what do you do with
five hundred thousand dollars
when it's set in the middle of your
kitchen table all of a sudden in 100
bills what do you do with that
well obviously we want to be wise with
it
overall there's three things you can do
with money you can give it
you can enjoy it
and you can invest it
and those are the three things you can
do and you really probably should do all
three of those things with this money
now we teach a thing called the baby
steps and so
my son is about your age if he inherited
that all of a sudden i would advise him
and he would already know
because he's my son to walk right up the
baby steps with that money and um you
know where would that take you are you
aware of all of that
yeah so i actually have no doubt other
than my house which you owe how much on
them uh 159 so i was planning on writing
a check for that pretty soon after
everything's closed okay um then that
puts you at what we call baby step seven
where there's nothing left to do but
build wealth and be generous you
remember that does that sound familiar
to you yes
okay
jonathan that's an incredible place to
be but i know it doesn't feel like it
right now
yeah i know you're you're hurting um i
think it's awesome that you're calling
and you're getting
wise counsel on what to do with this
large amount of money
you're already taking the right steps
you've already handled this before it
may have been a different amount of
money but you've gone through this and
so i want you to lean on those skills
and let that give you a sense of peace
and confidence as you as you walk this
out again
and then know as you do
yeah you're in a really good position
financially to do
anything you want to you're young to
have this what a gift that your uncle
left you at your young age you'll never
have dead again
ever
i mean that's an incredible gift and
legacy
that he gave you
and um and i know you're hurting right
now and it's hard to even feel that
and that's okay too that's okay so one
of the things i try to do um
that i have done gradually i never got a
uh
in the early days anyway i never got a
half million dollar check at one time
come into my life but
what i did gradually is i increased my
knowledge
uh by putting experts in my corner to
teach me
and that's kind of where we came up with
the saying with endorsed local providers
or with smart investor pros when you're
meeting with people in the money space
you need someone with the heart of a
teacher
not someone to boss you around and
because i hate it when people say well i
couldn't buy a car my advisor told me i
couldn't
i'm like it's not your advisor's money
youtube
it's your money
you tell your advisor what to do they
just give you advice
um and so that's just a cop out meaning
i don't have enough so i want you to
have enough backbone to make your own
decisions
as opposed to that person i just
outlined but i want you to put some
advisors some teachers
in your corner
and so you know you do need to meet with
a smart vester pro
and learn about some investing options
um
what are your thoughts on the house you
you uh you're probably not going to keep
it if you want to keep it as a rental
you can
i i think it's going to be troublesome i
don't know if you're going to have the
money with everything you've outlined to
completely pay your house off unless you
keep it number two when you run out your
uncle's house and a renter doesn't take
care of it one time that's going to be
very very very emotional
um people don't realize that like when
you move out of a house that you lived
in and then you rent it out it's a
it's
renters are even the best people in the
world including when i was a renter it's
not your house and it's just a weird
feeling to go back in there and go oh
look what they did to them yes my little
boy's bedroom you know it just does that
to you you can't keep yourself from
doing that so i doubt you're going to
keep it if you want to fight to keep it
that's fine as a rental
i wouldn't keep it sitting there empty
as a museum to your uncle i think that's
a bad idea
but so you need a good insurance person
in your corner that's an independent
insurance broker that can help you with
all the different kinds of insurance you
need in your life you need a good
investing professional in your corner
that you know like a smart investor pro
that it has the heart of a teacher and
will lead you in each of those areas you
need a good tax person a cpa in this
case you've already engaged a lawyer to
help you with the process so all of
these different experts in these
different areas are to teach you
something about
that area so that you can make good
decisions
they're not there to boss you around
they actually work for you you're paying
them and so they need to keep that
in mind i've had to fire a couple people
in the professions over the years that
decided their job was to tell me what to
do with my life instead their job is to
teach me and then i get to decide what
i'm going to do based on that knowledge
with my life they must not have known
you very well well i mean i just know
that would not fly away
no that's probably true but i mean i i
remember you know
uh
well it's just it doesn't matter but the
the uh an attorney one time that was
just telling us that this is the way
this has to be and i said no it doesn't
have to be that way i'm not doing it and
he goes well you know that that yeah you
know yeah and he just the arrogance of
it and finally i just said look i think
we're i think we're done
what do you mean we're done i said i
think you're fired
because i'm not gonna i'm not here for
you to tell me what to do i'm here for
you to teach me
and convince me
that this is the wisest and in the
multitude of counsel there is safety and
that's what you want you want
a group of counsel in your life that'll
walk with you through this jonathan and
teach you
and that'll help you keep from making
unwise decisions
and
and of course the overall arching rule
is don't take financial advice from
broke people including your broke
friends and they all have a lot of
opinions right now
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage matthew
and alicia are with us hey guys how are
you doing good dave how are you better
than i deserve welcome good to have you
where do you guys live
we lit we live in uh
washburn just a little bit above
knoxville here yeah from tennessee okay
awesome welcome to nashville good to
have you and all the way here to do a
debt-free scream yes sir love it how
much have you guys paid off we have paid
off 54
266 dollars in 14 months i love it good
for you and your range of income during
that 14 months
60 000
okay what do you guys do for a living
i'm a psych nurse part-time and a
full-time mama okay
and i am a 4-h extension agent for the
university of tennessee awesome cool
very cool i love it very fun well
welcome to nashville and congratulations
what kind of debt was the 54 000
we had a little bit of everything
we had a farm loan
a student loan
truck loan credit cards
furniture
cell phone we can keep going if you want
us to cause we're normal you had
everything very never met a debt you
didn't like a wide variety yeah had a
pretty famous saying you can't have
anything without having debt
all right it might have been wrong
[Laughter]
i might have been wrong ouch
i took a real man to stand up on that
stage and say that i'm just saying
brother that was good it hurt i might
have been wrong oh
that's a hard one yeah good for you well
what happened what's the story for 14
months ago
we'd better back up just a little
farther
about six and a half years ago right
before me and alicia got married my
father-in-law or soon to be
father-in-law he uh
offered to put us through financial
peace university
and i was a pretty good commercial for
huggies and i decided i was a big kid
now
and uh i said
i can manage my own money i don't need
anyone to tell me what to do
so we tried that
um of course i shared with you how that
worked out
but
about three years ago right before
madeleine our youngest was born um
we got to a point that money was getting
pretty tight alicia was getting ready to
go on maternity leave and uh
she got to the point that she was hiding
money
because she knew if it was just sort of
left out and around in the bank account
i would spend it
and so uh that got her attention a
little bit and she started paying off a
few loans on her own she said i want to
do this i said well okay you go ahead
do what you want to i said i'm not going
to stop you
but then just after that one of my 4-h
volunteers that we work with she she
come to me and said i want to use one of
your buildings that you all rent out
i said okay she i said what are you
using it for and she said the
financial peace university i said hey
my wife would love to do that
[Laughter]
she needs it
as a matter of fact her father said we
should do that so so from there we uh we
sort of got in line to do that and then
just just after that she came back in
the office and brought me the total
money makeover book and her husband had
wrote a note in there uh telling us to
sit down and read the book and to start
with the last chapter
and so uh i did that over a bowl of
cheerios
and dave i had a meltdown
it's true that
grown men do cry
and i realized the shape that i
put our family in
and the opportunity lost
and i said we've got to do something um
and that was in january of 2019 or 2020.
oh just in time for trump and time for
coal
and uh so we got our emergency funds in
got our uh or got our starter emergency
fund and then started in on the debt
snowball come february
and 14 months later
we're done wow
wow that's impressive yes
so uh lots of opportunity before you
very little behind you that was lost
you're okay yeah you got plenty of time
you guys are heroes you took control of
your lives that's right that's pretty
impressive and you're young
thank you how old are you two i'm 27.
and i'll be 33 in just a little while
all right very good well congratulations
you guys very proud of you too very
proud of you
so uh i'm guessing alicia your dad is
grinning
yeah
i'm guessing he's going took a little
while but it got there yeah yeah that's
good i like that little i told you so
along the way
wow yeah you probably earned it okay
okay that's okay and you're the kind of
guy i can take it you're alright you're
all right you're you're you're a
stand-up dude well done well done
there's something uh
powerful uh
about realizing
that i've got a huge potential in my
future and i've messed up and the how
quickly you turned on that matthew it
was that's powerful the way you told
that story yeah
um there's a little story behind that
dave i
lost my dad three years ago to
pancreatic cancer and
he said something of course you know
dads always say stuff they're pretty
unforgettable sometimes it's taken the
hard way
but he shared something in a hospital
bed
on how to
beat this thing this thing being cancer
and uh
my stepmother at the time she said how's
that be really strong and fight hard he
said no
he said be weak
just be weak and let god work
and uh
you know i had a lot of pride
and i had to put my pride aside now and
let a little weakness in
so that god could work and that's how we
done it
so i'm guessing that
the last 14 months have been pretty
impactful on your marriage as well oh
yeah turned it completely around yeah
that's so powerful what you just said
though matthew because there are people
lots of people yeah there's single girls
out there going this guy got a brother
sorry i don't
but there no listen there there are a
lot of people that do not have the
courage right
to realize what you realized and even
say what you said i was wrong they'd
rather stick to their guns defend their
mess
keep keep sticking to their their motto
if you can't have anything without debt
and making excuses
the rest of their life yeah and the fact
that you the courage to go
i was wrong
and i'm going to do something different
you're now
so young and completely debt-free and
you have the rest of your lives to build
wealth and do anything you want to
that's incredible and it's it came down
to that moment
and you having the courage to do that
well done
people what do you guys tell people the
trick to getting out of that is
a lot of communication good
communication and trust in your spouse
amen
budget's a pretty big deal yeah knowing
where that's where that money's going
pretty big deal
um and of course we we've done financial
peace university with our church we
facilitated that oh and uh well it was
our honor it was a it was a pleasure to
get to do that but one thing we shared
with them um going into it it's not a
money thing
it's a god thing
you let him control you
and he'll take care of the rest of it
he'll fall in order okay very cool
and you brought the kiddos with you what
are their names and ages let's get them
in the shot we have addison she's five
and madeleine that's two
awesome how fun oh they're so cute what
a great trip what a great trip very cool
we've got a copy of legacy journey for
you that's definitely the next chapter
in your story you have changed your
family tree over in so many many ways
i'm so proud of y'all yes what a neat
couple and of course also a copy of the
total money makeover and you can write
in the front of it and give it away to
somebody and get them going as well
that'll be great pay it forward very
cool stuff again very very proud of you
guys very very well done thank you
matthew alicia addison and madeline just
took off
north north of knoxville over in east
tennessee where i'm from 54 000 paid off
in 14 months making 60 a year count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two
one we're dead
[Applause]
yeah you do this uh
uh
i saw a signed bumper sticker this
weekend that i hadn't seen before god is
god says u-turns are legal
i like it so yeah
when you're going the wrong way and you
go and you turn and you go back the
other way in christianity we call that
repentance yeah but everybody else just
calls it a u-turn yep whatever you call
it sometimes we need it so
i mean matthew he slammed on the brakes
did a did a slide into a donut and did a
u-turn i love it powerful powerful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsay personality is my
co-host today welcome to the ramsey show
common sense for your
dollars and cents as we talk about your
life and your money elisa is with us in
atlanta hi elisa how are you
hi james hi christy i'm doing good how
are you guys great how can we help
um so my husband and i have been
following your plan for a while but we
in the last year or two here have become
self-employed and we've really had like
an income problem trying to keep
uh cash flow going so even making
progress on paying off the debt has been
difficult
um
we're in a situation right now
where we've had some medical bills come
up that have increased our debt we also
didn't
because of the cash flow issues didn't
have enough saved up for
taxes uh for 2020 so we
you know set up a payment plan with the
irs and all that want to get that out of
the way
um but we're also trying to make sure we
save up taxes for the coming year
um
properly
and i know
that you say
like baby step zero is basically like
getting
uh current on all your bills and not
going to into any more debt and that
sort of thing so i've been just
a little
confused on what order i should be
attacking these things in because these
medical bills are technically current um
but we also don't have the money to pay
them right now we had like a couple of
emergency rooms
so what's going on with your business
what do you what do you both do and what
do you make
um my husband
has a video production business right
now he's primarily doing some video
editing
freelance work as
that and then i have a proofreading
freelance
you have a what freelance proofreading
proofread
okay and what do y'all make combined
uh
last year our
uh income on our taxes was
uh oh crud i just forgot i think it was
about 32 000 um
or probably less than that yeah what
what did you do before that
sorry
how many kids how many kids do you have
it's just the two of us okay what did
you do before this you said you recently
became self-employed what did you all
used to do that and and what's the story
there
uh so
last year actually in the middle of the
pandemic my husband launched his video
production business
and that was a good move because before
that he was working
a pretty low paying server job
i was
a full-time employed as a proofreader
and then i
i've done like some over eats driving
and stuff since then and and one other
w-2 job for a few months this year but
that ended up not working out yeah you
know what i'm calling bs back and forth
i'm calling bs
your husband made more as a server than
he did in the video business
it was not a good it was not a good it
was not a good thing it was a good thing
in that servers disappeared during kovid
but
in terms of he launched into he didn't
exactly go make a fortune you guys are
living up i think your 32 000 is wrong
all you've told me in the first five
minutes you've been on the air is how
like six different times is how you guys
have absolutely no money i think you're
living below the poverty level and y'all
are running around calling this a
successful business it's not it's failed
you need to get jobs i i don't know
here's what i'm confused about alisa is
what you just told me in terms of your
you know y'all went through the debts
and getting your bills current all that
what i hear though is you sound okay
with the amount of money you all make
and you don't make enough money
why are y'all not out there getting
second and third jobs and getting your
income up
well
i
actually no like we're
aware
that we're struggling and we need more
money i've been working
i think you are what i can't figure out
for you i'm getting the okay
um i will say that the numbers have been
going up the last few months
significantly where we're looking at
we're looking at him bringing in
bringing home
like 2 000 at least this month uh which
is a significant increase and it's been
trajectory upward
um
are you all charging enough
say that again are you are each of you
charging enough is it a lack of
uh not the right pricing or do you not
have enough clients or both do you know
what those what the source of the
income problem revenue problem is
uh the primary problem has been
lack of clients uh what the clients he
has right now are definitely paying
appropriate amounts for the video
editing work he's doing okay yeah he's
not working much
he has been the last couple months we
had a lot of issues with like the first
six months this year yeah but but like i
mean two thousand bucks video editing in
a month he's not working much well and
my other thing though at least like okay
so today's point about like what we're
both saying about this income issue is
like starting a video production
business
you can do video editing almost anytime
you want you can serve at a restaurant
lots of different options of shifts and
hours i don't know why he's not doing
both video editing on the side working
as many hours as he can as a server he
could double his income right there
if he had kept the server job
yeah that i agree so here's what i'm
hearing and you you can correct me what
you're saying you can you can go
you can go do whatever you want to do
lisa but here's what i'm hearing okay
he launched a video business and he
loves to do the video work
and he's good at the video work itself
he is not good at marketing and getting
new clients and he's not good at running
a business because he's starving to
death
and you're starving to death with him
meanwhile you're over here trying to
plug up the 42 holes in this boat with
only two fingers and you're working like
three different jobs while he's working
one
that's not working it that's not working
out so if i were to come into your all's
lives what i would tell him to do today
he needs to do one of two things he
either needs to go get a job in the
video business and make four times what
he's making now working for somebody
else that knows how to go get clients
and then builds him out as an editor or
as a producer or as behind a camera or
whatever he's good at
um or
until he gets
or if he's going to keep doing this he
needs to get three side jobs in addition
to this and i want him working 80 hours
a week starting now
with uber with deliver with delivering
pizzas with working
at the restaurant serving so that he can
keep his video business alive
so his family can stay alive while he
runs his video business and learns how
to be a marketer and learns how to
learns his business acumen to run his
business because he's killing you
he's killing you sitting on his butt
listen the way these ducks land on your
plate cooked is you have to go leave
your house and shoot them
and then you have to pluck them
and then you cook them
but they don't fly in the door and land
on the plate
in business
you have to go get them and he hasn't
developed that skill yet he's not a bad
guy he's an artist and he's probably
very good at his craft and he's probably
not lazy
he's just not got a good game plan right
now he's got to go
duck hunting meanwhile he needs to go
make some freaking money and this is why
we tell you all we tell you all this all
the time not just you elisa i mean every
one of you listening that's why we tell
you
start your new business idea on the side
build it up in addition to your
full-time income because nothing will
kill your dream like not having any
money and getting to a place of
desperation it takes the joy right out
of it elisa if you will stay on the line
i'm gonna have kelly give you a live
stream ticket to our business boutique
conference you and your husband can
watch it together the business principle
supply regardless it will give him and
you
tons of tactical steps of what to do to
market your individual businesses and
your services in order to get more
clients and make more money stay on the
line kelly can give you that and that
will give you guys something to to get
started in this direction in addition to
everything else we're telling you to do
but stanford listen my wife has never
been a wife in 39 years that wasn't
supportive elisa
but she also her method of supporting
sometimes was to tell me the truth
and you're participating in delusion
with him the language you're using the
way you're taking up for this failed
business endeavor it's a hobby it's
you're starving to death he is not a
success yet
can he be
yes but not doing what he's been doing
for the last year and a half
and two thousand dollars
you know you make that in two weeks
delivering pizza
you know so we're not successful yet
don't participate in that so love him
enough to walk with him encourage him i
think he can be a big deal but he ain't
yet
he's not even a little deal yet
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
christy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and author of
the newly released
on sale as a pre-sale anyway new book
called take back your time the guilt
free the guilt free guide
to life
balance so we'll be talking about your
life and your money this hour it's a
free call triple eight eight two five
five two two five and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it all right nick is with us nick is in
colorado springs hey nick how are you
i'm good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
hey i had a question about uh whether i
should finish my debt spellball paying
off my student loans or if i should
refinance at this time since the rates
are so low
um i owe about ten thousand dollars on
my student loans and my rate right now
and i could buy down the
15-year mortgage for one point seven
five
you i mean your rate currently on your
mortgages how much
uh three and one eight
three point one two five
okay and you said you were quoted what
uh 1.75 on my 15 year
fixed rate
six straight bunch of points how many
points
right now they've gone down a lot 0.875
so a little under one percent
uh sounds low okay i'm a little
suspicious i i don't think mortgage
rates are below one percent or below two
percent yet
um yeah unless i missed something over
the weekend uh which is possible but i
don't think i did
okay so
they always have the best rate i have my
mortgage with them right now
okay oh it's a local credit union what's
the balance on your loan
uh 295.
okay well that's a below market rate
i'll just say it that way okay so that's
not bad so let's just call it two
percent down from three you would
refinance just for that but we don't
roll your debt into your mortgage
yeah i didn't want to load in so what's
that got what's the eleven thousand
dollar student loan got to do with the
equation then
oh i'm just going to that's the one i
wanted to see if i should finish paying
the debt or if i should refinance money
oh i see is there any cost uh out of
pocket to refinance
oh no
then why would it affect you that
snowball
because it because the payment's going
up going to a 15 year
yeah it's gonna go about five six
hundred dollars ah okay now i'm catching
on okay i'm a little slow on the uptick
sorry about that
all right
um okay so the big concern is not money
out of pocket
um it's not rolling the student loan
into the refinance it's simply you're
going to have a higher payment and
that's going to slow down how fast you
can get your your
student loan paid off right
what do you make
uh
about 95 000
okay
it's a good question took me a minute to
get to the bottom of it because i'm like
i said i wasn't gathering i was i was
telegraphing where you were going and it
was none of those places okay so
um
yeah yes you do this
it's not gonna slow it down that much
500 bucks a month increase in payment
changes your cash flow six thousand
dollars a year making ninety thousand
that doesn't keep you from getting out
of debt
okay it does slow it down a little bit
but it might slow it down by two months
or something is always yeah on that
income yeah it's it's so different than
the call we just had before the break
too because you have such a great income
nick you're gonna get out of debt
quickly
whether or not you refinance or not so
you can refinance and get a debt still
in a very short amount of time because
you have such a great income that's the
reason we talk to people about getting
their income up whether it's through
business taking a second job third job
the bigger shovel you have the more
progress you can make on your goals
whatever those goals are but if you
don't have an income there's you're just
you're tight there's not a lot you can
do that's right you're doing great nick
that's awesome luke is with us luke is
in charlotte north carolina hi luke how
are you
holiday hello christy hi so as with most
as with most questions you guys probably
answered this before however i haven't
quite heard it be asked in the time i've
been listening so dude i've been
answering the same questions for 30
years that ain't no thing
go ahead and ask it we're ready
all right so my question is just kind of
determining whether or not i'm on step
six or seven um
so i've had i have all milestones
essentially met the conundrum i'm in is
that i still rent so i technically don't
have a mortgage uh even though step six
is paying essentially paying off the
mortgage could i consider myself as kind
of paying myself
a mortgage payment a month
on top of what i've already saved for my
down payment which is above your
recommended amount or would that kind of
put me in a step 7
instead
it doesn't matter
you're doing great
i'm so proud of you how old are you
uh 28. all right man you're doing good
well done so the bottom line is you
don't have any debt you have an
emergency fund in place and you're
putting 15 of your income into
retirement right yep wow look at you
freaking rock star and then every other
dollar you save right now is called down
payment money because the bigger the
down payment the smaller the debt the
faster the house does get paid off when
you buy it right
absolutely so just make it real clean
anything that's not an emergency fund
that's in savings is increased down
payment
we don't have to have two categories of
it just pile up a big old pile of
money and go in and buy a house and
almost pay for it or pay for it i'd love
it how much you got saved already for
the house
about 53
5'3
yes way to go you're doing awesome what
is your income
uh 91 000. good for you
yeah you're rocking this man so um
i'm so if you bought a 200 000 house
today you put down 25 that'd be cool you
know and if you you know and if you wait
three or four years you probably just
pay cash for it
yep yeah that's kind of where i was
going with this question is uh
considering how concerning how much i
have i feel it's quite difficult taking
out the debt considering how much i'm
able to save per month luke you're
awesome
i'm in no hurry to buy you're awesome
here's the reason you don't fit in one
one of the baby steps just perfectly is
because you're not normal normal people
have a house payment and car payment and
student loans and all the debt and we
walk them through which is great because
this plan works for the normal person
has normal debts you're not normal you
haven't bought a house yet you're
possibly saving up to either put a huge
down payment or pay cash you're just
gonna fast track yourself to baby step
seven you're doing amazing ding ding
yeah i love it well done sir yes
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you don't have
it on your calendar yet september the
16th christy wright will be doing a live
event on life balance and she's allowing
me to participate
since i owned the freaking company
so nice of me yes it was so sweet of you
you're sweet that way you're good to me
give the old man some work to do
so anyway she's she's the star of the
show and i'll be the uh i'll be there
for the window dressing or whatever
so check it out uh it's all about life
balance it's on september the 16th you
can check out getting your tickets
getting your reservation for the live
stream at ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're glad you're here if you
like your job but you feel like you
don't have a plan for what's next or you
need help climbing the career ladder we
got some great news for you ken coleman
america's career coach ramsey
personality has poured his years of
proven experience into a new book from
paycheck
to purpose
the clear path
to doing work you love
it's available for pre-sale right now
and you need this book
there isn't another how-to guide out
there that will show you exactly step by
step what you do to get into your dream
job and to promote a long way and grow
your career if you pre-order today
you'll receive the get promoted bonus
pack for free it includes an audio
lesson on promotions the disk assessment
free live stream access to kins
from paycheck to paycheck from paycheck
to purpose
live event and a 30-day free trial to
ramsey plus and more it's over a hundred
dollars almost two hundred dollars worth
of stuff
free when you buy this 20 book on
pre-sale at
ramseysolutions.com also we're giving
away 500 cash every week this month and
a grand prize of three thousand dollars
at the end of august and while you're
there christy's new book is also on
pre-sale take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance we have
two books right now coming out this fall
both of them in pre-sale right now
christie's will actually launch on
september the 14th in ken's in early
november uh enter at enter daily for
extra chances to win the ramsey cash
giveaway no purchase necessary you got
to be 18 years old or older text cash
for the free cash to 33 789 and you can
enter for the giveaway that's cash to
33789
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee meaning if you screw up if you
miss measure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from mandy in
washington i have a cleaning business
that provides services to vacation
rentals in a nearby tourist town i have
many long time clients an excellent
reputation for detailed work because
finding workers is difficult these days
i've had to increase what i pay them by
five to ten dollars an hour the cost of
supplies has also gone up i recently let
my clients know that their cleaning fee
would increase in a few weeks
several rental owners understand and
agree with it but if you are just rude
one of them wants to know what i charge
all my other clients what's a good
response to this type of request bye-bye
i haven't even finished the question
you can't help yourself
i have no clients coming on board at the
higher rate so there's no lack of
business right
right you just answered your own
question mandy i have new clients coming
on board at the higher rate so there's
no lack of business they're gone
bye just like dave said
bye they're gone here's the thing
there's such a fear in business that if
you raise your prices you're going to
lose people and the reality is you will
and you'll lose the ones you need to
lose
you'll lose the ones that are rude that
you're spending all of your time and
energy on that are headaches more often
than not if someone is demanding to know
what you charge and what you do that is
none of their business
at literally it's not their business
i mean literally it's your business not
there yeah that's a good point that's a
good point that's where the saying comes
from yes
and so you don't have to feel bad if
someone is rude yeah they no longer are
a client and you wish them the best
thanks for your business best luck out
there i mean it's to me this is a very
simple i know it doesn't feel like it
when you're dealing with actual people
and and you care and you wanna you know
but but if someone's gonna have the
nerve to be rude to you you have to have
the nerve to kindly show them the door
yeah you're right so here's what happens
um
you don't get
hard-hearted
or calloused
hopefully
the longer you're in business
but what experience does give you
is the knowledge that cutting those
folks loose
is you didn't realize how much time they
were already taking of yours that's
exactly right because people that are
going to be a rude client are usually
your highest maintenanced clients always
they take up more of your time you make
less money on them and so there's always
a percentage of your business
of your revenue in business that you
should always consider firing
so that you can spend time on the it's
it's what we call bad business it's
business that you're doing it's not it's
not good it's not worth the trouble
right and but you know someone that says
oh you mean
you mean you're having to pay more for
labor and you mean your supplies costs
went up uh and uh oh the way i'm going
to respond to that is i'm going to be
rude to you
um instead of saying you know what gosh
i've always enjoyed working with you but
i guess i'm gonna have to clean it
myself because i can't afford it right
to do that
and so
it's it's been good though right that's
the way you leave if you can't afford it
but people that can't afford it
sometimes are the meanest yeah or they
can't afford it they just don't want to
and so they're mean and that's where it
comes down to you having the yeah you
having the confidence to let them go and
know that you're going to be okay you've
already said you will be mandy you have
no
lack of business
and so you have permission to set these
people free you know how my mom would do
it dave
she would fire customers in the kindest
way so she was obviously in the wedding
cake business so she'd get some
bridezillas momzilla's all the whole
gamut you can imagine yeah
and so what she would realize is is
truly she would spend
90 percent of her time and energy on her
10
most difficult customers the rest of
them are easy right and so when she
found it was time to fire a customer
which she got good after 30 years of
doing this identifying those red flags
early on here she'd say something like
this like
you know what this is your wedding day
and i want you to be happy you should be
happy
and i can just tell by us talking about
this i'm not gonna be able to make you
happy and i want you to be happy so here
are some different places you can go
check out for wedding cakes that'll make
you happy i wish you the best isn't that
the nicest thing you've ever heard but
this but what she did was she fired them
well you know and the beautiful thing
about this is the net effect was she
sent all the ugly customers to her
competitors i knew you were going to
point that out
you got a stack of business cards or
your your competitors talking i'm out
i think that's genius yeah you're so
nice you're high maintenance go see my
competitor put it back on them you go
you should be happy absolutely clearly i
want
i can't meet all your expectations you
put it right back on them jesus couldn't
make you happy darling so you need to go
yeah you know what's interesting though
every now and then one of them would
straighten up oh no no no no i no this
is fine and they would start to behave
as a good behaving customer but she
taught them hey if you're going to do
business with me you're going to respect
the way that i do business and i'm going
to respect you and so on but every now
and then one of them was straightened up
and they could stay but if not they have
to be fired most of the time it's not
most of the time
so what what we're saying is when i when
i interrupt in the middle of you reading
that and i say bye-bye
that's from 30 years
of
the first time i did it i almost cried i
was no you did yes i did because i was
so scared that i was going to mess up
the whole world and somebody wasn't
going to like little dave ramsey yeah
you know and then once i figured out
crap about half the world doesn't like
dave ramsey we just need to get that's
okay now you know it's like the other
half's doing pretty good for me it's all
right you know i'll be all right you
know so you know
twitter trolls and everything else so
you just you reach the point you go
it didn't kill me and it didn't kill
them yeah and that also gives you the
power to be nice it does like your mom
was because she knew it wasn't they
could get a cake made somewhere else
absolutely and what's interesting is you
don't realize how much of the emotional
energy and time that were wrapped up in
those people and you're so much freer
yeah you're so much freer when you let
those people go and you know there's
once you've done it for a decade
and you go
i've turned loose of five to ten percent
of my business every year i let them go
in the name of they're not worth the
trouble yeah and i did it in a kind but
powerful and strength way based way once
you've done it a bunch then you read
something like this you can get halfway
through it and go bye-bye yeah and it's
not hard-hearted it's not calloused no
it's like they're gonna live through it
it's just freaking getting your house
cleaned they're gonna live through it
they self-selected by how they behaved
yeah but how they treated you they chose
that not you
exactly and then there's the other bunch
that are just crazy yeah they gotta go
too yeah there's about two percent of
the public should be
institutionalized and you really just
don't want them as a customer for sure
so you just fire them quick
and that's a little more joyful
but but you know don't there's no reason
for you to i don't like our customer
care people don't call and yell and cuss
at them because i tell them we'll just
take you out of the database
we don't get they don't get paid enough
to put up with your crap call in here
with a problem and be nice and we'll
help you with it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
christie wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today her new book take back
your time the guilt-free guide to life
balance is on pre-sale right now
jay and heather are with us they are in
minneapolis and it says on my screen you
guys are debt-free
congratulations thank you dave congrats
how much of you guys paid off
128 000
good for you awesome how long did this
take
it took us 15 years
okay cool and your range of income
during that time
45 to 80 000.
okay cool what do y'all do for a living
these days
i'm an i.t director for a library system
and i'm a stay-at-home mom of nine kids
and i homeschool them
nine kids
you guys have got a lot of mouths to
feed and still got your way out of debt
huh
yup we started off with one kid when we
started the baby steps and we added
eight along the way and they were all
paid for with cash
no no repossessions to date huh okay
that's good that's incredible heather i
can never complain about being too busy
with my three children again that's
amazing
so uh 128
yeah so 128 000 is that house and
everything
house and everything 20 000 student loan
and that was paid off in the first 13
months and then the mortgage after that
wow wow way to go you have a paid for
house
look at you man did you ever think you'd
have a paid for house
not before the plan but once we got on
on track and knew the plan we knew we'd
get there oh definitely yeah but i mean
back in the day like because people
don't think walk around going you know
i'm gonna have no mortgage when i'm
older you know people don't say that
much good for you man how old are you
guys
i'm 45 and heather's 42. okay cool
awesome so tell us the story what got
you started on all this 15 years ago
well um we had our first kid and we were
wanting to heather to be able to keep
staying at home and to be able to home
school and money was tight um i heard
you on focus on the family way back then
and then i got excited about your
message
i got the book uh financial p or uh
yeah financial piece first
um and then i introduced you to heather
and it turned out she'd already heard
your message somewhere months before
that and couldn't get me couldn't get it
through to me
of course you came around when it was
your idea right jake
exactly
man that was long enough ago probably dr
james dobson was still on there wasn't
he
it might have been yeah it was this long
time yeah that's cool very neat very fun
and so you start you you she now that
she uh realized that it was your idea we
could start this and here we go right
yes exactly i love it very cool and you
paid off student loan quickly so what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of that house and everything with nine
kids
yes
well you have to want it and then you
have to start it's it's not something
you can just want and and just want and
get it it's hard work it's not easy to
keep going when it gets rough when you
have you know oh we need to get a 15
passenger van now that's kind of
discouraging but you just keep going um
with the
the mortgage it was challenging because
we didn't have that debt snowball to
build all the momentum with so it was
just a slog once we got to the mortgage
also envelopes are very important
plastic just takes way too much
discipline even if it's just a debit
card
um okay lots of envelopes at your place
then oh lots of bundles okay cool
this is so interesting so sometimes i
read uh
ridiculous posts on social media that
say things like well that dave ramsey
stuff doesn't work if you have a large
family and then i have large family
people chime in and say it's the only
thing that
works yeah it really is you know
it's it's bad enough you know all the
things you have to think about with a
big family
but to have those
debt considerations in the back of your
mind just nagging at you it's it's very
freeing that we just have one less thing
to think about now
yeah no house payment a major thing that
you don't have to think about no house
payment that's that's like
yeah and and so all we do is we all we
just make enough to feed all these baby
birds and clothe them and make sure we
have a 19 passenger van and all that
stuff man that's pretty incredible dude
that's just beautiful i love it i'm so
proud of you guys how does it feel thank
you
i think it feels fun we actually get to
make choices with our budget now instead
of just buckling down and moving along
like the tortoise now we get to you know
hop around and have fun and we can give
some and we can
go i'll go out to eat as a whole family
which is something we very rarely ever
have done
yeah how was it how was it with the kids
with those nine kids in a variety of
ages range of ages i'm sure in there
through this journey was that something
y'all talked about as a family kind of
getting everybody bought into this this
vision as a family of what you are doing
well you know we started early enough
that we didn't have to get anybody to
buy in we just told them how it was
going to be yeah well that's that's for
sure
it's really turning out good now as we
have a 16 year old
and heather has been working really hard
to get him through college without any
debt and without a huge amount of money
in a college fund because we just have
baby college funds for everybody so
she's been doing a lot of testing for
credit and he's starting uh
post-secondary post-secondary enrollment
here in the fall and he's probably going
to get out with only a few dollars out
of pocket to get his degree wow his very
first car this week debt-free wow all
right what did he buy
oh it's just an old 2003 taurus it's uh
you know your hooptie yeah what do you
pay for it
one thousand dollars i love this kid
go you too he's going to school
he's gonna go to school debt free and he
bought his first car for a thousand
bucks cash he's 16. he's already
planning to go to college debt-free
absolutely
he's basically halfway done already
hey america you know what that's called
parenting
[Laughter]
wow
yeah the inmates don't run the asylum
when you have nine they do what they're
told that's amazing guys
you guys are incredible i'm so impressed
with you yes man what a man what a great
model
very very cool
very cool well uh we've got a copy of
the legacy journey for you because for
sure that's the next uh
chapter in your story without a doubt
and a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away to somebody and get
them started uh you've got a lot of
arrows in your quiver that you'll be
able to release and it sounds like they
know how to fly straight already
which is good parenting and so um
you know the they're just fabulously
done you guys very very well done 128
000.
all right i tell you what we need to uh
we don't need to break tradition here we
need you guys to name off all nine names
and ages before you do your debt-free
scream quickly
all right we've got caleb 16 james 13
joshua 12 anna 10 micah 8 gideon 6 lydia
4 timothy 2 and ruth eight months all
right oh there we go awesome 128 000
paid off house and everything we're
talking to weird people 15 years it took
them to do it making 45 to 80. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
[Music]
[Applause]
all those little voices in the
background that is a family tree changed
and it's a big tree it's a big tree
well done you guys
well done okay so moral of the story
you don't have to make a gazillion
dollars to be debt-free no more of the
story large families not only can do the
principles we teach living on a plan
getting out of debt having an emergency
fund in place living on less than you
make these simple but hard to do
concepts that we teach every day
actually are the only shot a large
family has yeah you got no wiggle room
you got no margin for error when you
have nine mouths to feed right yeah no
that's true and it's interesting too
because whether you have a big family
small family or whatever your
circumstances
you can find an excuse if you look for
one oh we got a big family oh you don't
understand my situation yeah you can
look for an excuse and you'll find one
or you can just look for a way to make
it work and it does work and we see
people call in from all ages all stages
all different careers industry
industries and family sizes and they're
making it work because it's a principle
that can be applied regardless of your
family and i just i love that example
because that's such an extreme example
yeah well these principles are the truth
yeah it's like the law of gravity is the
truth it works it works for large
families too
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today mia is in sacramento hi
mia how are you
mia how are you
me it might be on mute maybe uh maybe i
didn't push the button right i'll put
her back on hold and all right let's try
sean in minneapolis hi sean how are
you hey i'm good how are you guys doing
good relief to hear your voice what's up
yeah i'm good um
so
i have recently picked up your total
money makeover from a used bookstore
i'm really glad that i did i saw a crazy
looking guy cutting up a credit card and
i thought what is this about
um and i just i totally dove in and i am
dead set on paying off all my debts and
i can't look forward
anymore to the day where i can come on
stage and do my death please scream with
my girlfriend anyway so good for you
my question is
my question is about the budget
and more specifically
the
things that you budget for that could
change on a month-to-month basis
so like doing your bills and your
mortgage is relatively easy because they
don't really change much at all if at
all
but i'm kind of struggling with the idea
of like how much money should we be
setting aside for
groceries or clothing um things like
that
i guess like do you guys go off of like
a percentage or is this like a flat
amount per person in the family what do
you recommend have you is this your
first time doing a budget
i've always had like a
a half
but
budget where
like i said i'm doing the easier things
um but it wasn't until i started using
the every dollar free app that i really
started so yeah
i'll tell you how i did it and that i
wasn't really doing it 100
yeah i'll tell you how i did it when i
got started budgeting and i think this
is how we teach it dave correct me if
i'm wrong but um what i did for my very
first budget is i looked at my bank
statement for the past three months to
see what was the average that i had been
spending on groceries or that type of
thing and it's not because i always
needed to spend that but it gave me some
type of range so i'm not setting some
ridiculously
uh unrealistic number and then i come up
the range okay i typically spend about
this much and then you can kind of
stretch yourself to a goal from there um
you know for for some of those things
that can fluctuate but because you do a
budget every month so for example um i
it's august right now and um i just went
back to school shopping for my kids they
needed some new clothes they've outgrown
some of the clothes and so on so i know
august is going to be a higher clothing
month before the month yeah you can
predict that right right before the
month i know august is going to be a
back-to-school shopping month whereas um
you know in july i'm not going shopping
for clothes for example so you will sit
down before the month begins every
single month and it's a it's a it's the
best guess you can based on past track
record and in line with your goals of
what you want to spend and where you're
going am i saying that right you did
perfectly okay perfectly and stuff like
even utilities will change from month to
month like we're in tennessee and so
it's really hot in the summers and so
our air conditioning bill our
electricity bill is higher in the winter
i heat my home with natural gas and so
my electric bill is fairly low but my
natural gas bill goes up in the winter
and so i can predict that december's gas
bill is going to be different than
june's
okay as an example right and i can look
at last year's i can look at last year's
and guess pretty close to what it's
going to be and on that kind of thing
you want to guess a little high
so you say okay you know last year's gas
bill was i don't know i'll make it up
235 or whatever okay well just go ahead
and round that to 250 and put that in
there and that way you got yourself a
little wiggle room if something comes up
and um and that's how you do it and then
the last piece is
that a lot of people including my wife
uses the envelope system
and we don't use it for everything but
for a few things you mentioned groceries
by the way a hint on groceries is
whatever you think you spend on
groceries before you actually start
living on a budget you're wrong it's
more
yes okay
if you think you spend 500 it's probably
more like 800. if you think you spent
800 it might be 1200. i'm not talking
about restaurants i'm talking about
groceries only separate groceries and
restaurants apart because restaurants
are entertainment and groceries are food
yes you get food at a restaurant but
most of what you pay for is the
experience of having someone else cook
it for you
and uh clean it and all that stuff so um
you know go that route with this and
you'll be much much better off now so
the envelopes all we do with that is we
say okay for the month i think we're
gonna spend eight hundred dollars and
put 800 cash in an envelope and write
food on the outside that envelope don't
buy anything out of that envelope except
food and don't buy any food except out
of that envelope no cheating
and so you are using cash that does two
things one is when that envelope gets
empty you know you've run out of money
and there's a little catch mechanism
there it's empty versus if you've got
plastic or even writing checks in the
old days you know you could just keep
going there was no there's nothing to
stop you and go uh oh
we've overspent the budget yeah and you
could do that for the back to school
clothes you could have a back-to-school
clothes envelope for august and say
that's it because
you know you got little boys going back
and that little boy stuff's cute is it
little girl stuff just about it's good i
mean it's fun dressing them up you know
and you could go crazy in there
easy enough and blow your amount and not
and have all kinds of rationalizations
and justifications but if you're looking
in that envelope at real hundred dollar
bills real 50 bills and they are leaving
it slows your butt down because you feel
it yeah i got a question about the
envelopes and maybe you've talked about
this and i've just missed it have you
talked at all about
the so envelopes
have this like built-in discipline right
like because it's visual you can see it
you know since the pandemic dave
everybody has so much so much online
shopping yeah and amazon
man add to cart is so easy
well i mean if you're if you're having
you're not using the envelope and i used
to i'll tell you one that's changed over
the years when we first started teaching
this
30 years ago you did not pay for
gasoline at the pump
yeah you walked inside to pay for it
right i do remember that old school
uh-huh i remember that and so i used to
carry and teach to carry a gasoline
envelope with cash to pay cash for your
gas and then when it goes up five
dollars a gallon you're like pissed at
the president right
and so um that kind of stuff right so
now but i haven't paid with my uh we
haven't had a gas envelope at the ramses
in years we pay with a debit card right
like you're doing online right at the
pump but so you've still got to budget
that
and keep track of it and you've got to
have some way and the every dollar
budgeting app will let you know but yeah
you've got you got to categorize each of
those expenditures yeah and when they
pop on your debit card especially if
you've got the premium edition where
it's what automatically logs and all
that right then you go okay drag and
drop drag and drop you're dragging that
expense over into the food category at
amazon dragging a food expense over
there oh and we've got some cash over
here then you look up and go crap we
just went 500 bucks over this is not
gonna work i can't do this well every
dollar makes it so fun and makes it so
easy to do but you're right because you
might have a grocery budget or clothing
budget and you spend the majority of
your monthly expenses out of that
envelope out of that category in cash
but then there's a percentage you get
amazon fresh or that you get a couple
clothing items off off online and you've
got to be able to reconcile that this is
all coming from the same budget line
item and it will drop down when you
start dropping those things over that
are that are transactions like you're
talking about but it's it's
it's important to pay attention to
because you've got things coming out of
different places and if you're not
careful that add to card will get you
man not that i know anything about that
add to cart
yeah i don't even know what that is so
you can add stuff they suggest people
like you buy things like this
and then you add to the cart it's it's
like it's not even that dave it's like
sometimes you're just having a day
you're like i don't i just need to add
some things to my cart just any cart
like this
the cart wasn't already had anything in
it no this is just brand new this is
just generally online shopping dave this
is not listen i guarantee you all the
women listening are going like yeah i
mean they make like doormats you're just
sitting around boards and going i need
to buy crap i mean
it's a real thing
they make they make dorm mats that say
like amazon man please hide the boxes
from my husband
online shopping is a real no i know i
knew i know but i mean i didn't know but
i know oh my god
like like you'll see on instagram a meme
that says it's an add to cart kind of
kind of day
okay so now you know retail therapy
online style 100 i'm glad i can help
them today boredom spending yes
it's a thing well i'd just be ashamed
i would just be ashamed i don't not only
do you know about it but but you've done
it oh my god i'd just be ashamed if i
were you
i felt no shame maybe i should i just
don't i feel no shame i'll do what i
want
uh i'm christy right that's it
that puts us our the ramsey show in the
books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host christy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book business
boutique her new book on pre-sale take
back your time the guilt-free guide to
life balance on sale now
for twenty dollars at ramsey solutions
includes 200 or 100 worth of goodies to
go with it including a
live stream event that she and i will be
doing on september the 16th
she'll be doing and i'll be doing a
little bit of it but i'll be there
and uh
he'll let you guys in on some uh some
life hacks when it comes to balance
she's gonna walk you through the process
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
melody is with us in dallas hi melody
welcome to the ramsey show hi guys
hey what's up hi thank you so much for
talking to me sure how can we help
um so my husband and i um we have four
kids they make about 50 grand a year and
that's just him i stay at home with the
kids
and we kind of got in over our heads
with our mortgage it's a little bit
tight
at the end of all of our bills
we have about
less than 200 that's able to go to
savings
um
and we're just wondering if we need
sorry i'm nervous you're doing great
take your time
we're just wondering um
what we need to do because we're we're
stuck here
um
and he kind of he's open to working a
second job
and um you know saving money until he
can go back to school or something but
he doesn't want it to be like you know
he lives his life working two jobs
um so he's kind of like i don't know
what to do here if i should try to work
up in my company because he likes his
company but he's just not making enough
right now
when you said i'm question i'm curious
about one part of your question melody
said we're stuck here
uh what do you mean by that i just want
to question that before we dig into all
this oh
yeah well we really like it here and
everything we feel great about the area
but it's um
it's a new developed neighborhood and
they said that they don't want anybody
to sell for at least a year
from buying so i don't work
can they determine that i don't think so
can they i don't know i was wondering is
that even legal i don't know
no it's not that's what they told us
it's not there's not a you don't have a
need restriction that prohibits you from
selling for a year
that's just uh okay so uh how much is
your house how much is your house
um
it's only at a thousand right now but
they said that because of um for tax
purposes it'll be
more like 14 next year
okay and then we have a
mud taxes for water and
it just adds up so fast yeah it was
fortunate
yeah
after taxes and with four kids yeah yeah
realistically we have to have a path for
his income to go up or you need to sell
the house one of the two
so you're asking right you're asking the
right questions
and it doesn't matter how much you like
it it's whether you can afford it and
you can't prosper with what you've got
there your house payment is probably
about 40 percent of your take-home pay
and to your husband's what we figured at
this point yeah to your husband's point
melody he doesn't want to work two jobs
forever as the path to keep this house
that he never gets to see so that's not
a good plan either you know what i mean
like short term if that could change
something that's fine
but not long term let me direct you to
kencoleman.com
ken is our ramsey personality that
teaches people
um
how to find what they're good at what
they love
and what gives them
some passion
and then
start and only then start asking the
questions what do i have to do to be one
of those
what do i have to do to get he calls it
get clear
on what you want to do and why you want
to do it what's your talent your passion
um what is it that um
you'd love doing and what you're good at
um and
then from that you go okay i don't i
don't necessarily have that degree or i
don't have that certification or i would
need to go be an apprentice to do that
from there you say all right i've got to
get qualified
and then i've got to get connected those
are the first three of his
steps of his path stages
to getting the work the dream job that
you love
so
moving up inside of his company might be
the answer but only if it's moving
towards something that he loves doing
and that he's good at
and that he's passionate about and he
sees himself jazzed on sunday morning on
monday morning
he's not there right now yeah so we need
to say okay
five years from today three years from
today two years from today what could i
be doing
if i could be doing anything i wanted to
do and i had all the necessary degrees
and there was nothing holding me back
what's my favorite thing in the world
and i could make
80 000 a year maybe
okay start asking yourself that and then
you don't take something just for money
for sure that's a bad idea but you also
don't take something just because it's
in front of you and you didn't see
anything else lately which is how he got
here
he just took a job
yeah
yeah and that's what most people do it's
not a bad thing but the good news is the
house is kind of giving you the wake-up
call so
i think you guys are to sit down
together with the kids in bed and you do
some soul-searching about what he's
going to do with his career and is that
then going to manifest itself into more
money
fast enough to keep our family from
being broke due to this house
and i think you i think when you run
those scenarios melody you start looking
at the numbers and go what does he need
to make
in order for you guys to stay in this
house and feel good about it and afford
it
and then yeah you know and is that
possible with this track that he's on
but then you look at the other option it
may actually be both it may be changing
careers
and you still realize
this isn't the house we need to stay in
in this season and that's okay when you
start to lay out all the options you
have
change careers second job sell the house
some combination of that you just start
to feel more in control because you
realize you're not painted in a corner
with two bad options you have more
options than you think so just spend
some time just like dave said when the
kids are down where you can just lay out
all the options on the table and that
will immediately reduce your stress
because you can see all of the paths to
get you to where you want to go and then
you can make the best decision does that
make sense
yeah for sure i also did want to ask you
if you thought it would be realistic for
me to try to do something from home
having four kids they're five and under
be tough
but it can be done it would it would
require you to give up any time that you
have by yourself right now so it would
be before they wake up or after they go
to bed that would be when that would
happen
realistically yeah and so it's just i
don't even know where to start
i don't have any kind of yeah i tell you
what we'll send you a couple of things
i'm going to send you a copy of
christie's book business boutique
which will help with your ideas of what
you m where you might start and i'm
gonna send you a copy of ken's book the
proximity principle
and i want your husband to get on ken
coleman.com tonight
because we need a track towards making
80 grand
and i don't care how what the track is
or if it's three months three years two
years one year
five years whatever i need a track
if you're not gonna put that track in
place you need to put this house up for
sale
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the ramsey show christy
wright number one best-selling author
and ramsey personality is my co-host
today answering your questions about
your life and your money if it feels
like no matter what you try to do or how
hard you work you cannot get ahead i
know the feeling
it's exhausting it's stressful and
sometimes even terrifying you do not
have to live like that
if you're sick and tired
of being sick and tired
decide that you're ready to do something
different
so that you get different results it's
time to commit to a plan that actually
works
financial peace university is the
step-by-step plan
that's helped millions and millions of
people pay off debt
and take control of their money combine
that with a premium version of the every
dollar budgeting tool and you'll make
progress right away
it's the own it's only available with a
membership to ramsey plus
decide today to break the cycle of
living paycheck to paycheck this month
only we're taking 30
off the price of a 12 month ramsey plus
membership and it's got tons of stuff in
it financial peace university in every
dollar are just part of it
start with a free trial of ramsey plus
today by texting trial to 33 789
text trial two three three
seven
eight nine michael is with us in las
vegas hey michael what's up hey how are
you doing dave better than i deserve how
can i help
hey so um i've never had any like
financial teachings except for like
youtube and that's where i found you um
i owe 280 000 on my house and i had 50
grand in the bank and i was wondering
should i just put that 50 right toward
the principal or put it in the market
and once it reaches my house payoff
then pull it out and pay off my house
do you have any other debt
no
do you have any other savings
yeah i have uh i have 50 000 in my uh
deferred comp retirement thing but i
can't pull it out
until
he's retired
well first of all way to go on being
debt free uh that's awesome you're in a
great position
you do want to have an emergency fund
you want to have a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses so i don't know what that would
be for you but you want to make sure you
set that aside and that's going to be in
cash in a savings account that you can
access anytime it doesn't need to be
invested it doesn't need to be
complicated and you don't want to put
that towards the house because you need
to access it if something goes wrong but
then the rest
what you're going to do is if
if you're not already investing on baby
step number four you want to invest 15
percent um on baby step number four and
then you take the rest and just put it
towards uh put it towards your house and
uh and drop that down you shouldn't have
any type of fees or penalties for paying
a larger sum at one time and that will
drop your uh drop your balance down and
you're just making progress at the same
time well maybe step six so michael the
deal is this um
i i i'm honored that you found us on
youtube
um
it uh
scares me that that's your only source
of information
um and i don't think we we lack
credibility we do we do this for a
living but you probably need to get some
books and some other things i'll send
you a copy of our best-selling book the
total money makeover which will walk you
through the whole process
process of building wealth and
christie's exactly on track there we
teach a process
that literally tens of millions of
people have done called the baby steps
which is the shortest distance between
where you are in wealth
which was the underlying question you
asked what's the fastest way for me to
get wealthy
meaning pay off my house have some money
is it put the money in the stock market
or does it pay off my house with the
money so you need an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses as she
outlined and you put the rest of it on
the mortgage the reason we say to do
that rather than invest the difference
is that um
the data that we have having studied ten
thousand millionaires
among those
that became millionaires uh
north of 80 of them
did so by two primary things which is
most of them in other words they got a
they got their home paid off and that
was a big chunk of their net worth and
they steadily invested into their
retirement accounts whether it's
deferred comp 401k
roth iras something along those lines
but usually it was 401ks and roth iras
deferred comps usually down the list
so um
you know that's what i would have you to
do is let's work to get the house paid
off and then when that's paid off not
having a house payment enables you to
invest a lot of money per month
and the
advantages that you're able to build
wealth very very quickly then sela is
with us in vancouver washington hi sila
how are you
hi dave thanks for answering my call
sure what's up
hey um so i am 24 years old i'm married
i just had we just had our first baby
he's 10 months old now um
congratulations and
thank you
it's been fun um inexpensive
so
so my question is um
here in vancouver washington as you guys
probably know the cost of living here is
astronomical um a decent house in a
decent neighborhood is anywhere from and
this is a minimum of 325 350 but you
know if you're going to get a sizable
house if we want to have another baby
and have a three bedroom it'd be like
four hundred thousand um and so the
twenty percent down payment is very a
very large amount and um i'm just
wondering for people my age especially
the millennial and gen z generation
um the option of zero down
so uh
we have 16 000 in our savings account um
we've got 2 000 in stock so we're going
to have 40 000 by august of this next
year
and um but we're just wondering if we
should just do zero down versus doing
all of the
versus wiping it out if that makes sense
well zero down i would not buy a house
that means you're it means you're if you
don't have any money you shouldn't buy a
house
that's a bad plan you're gonna get
yourself in a pinch
so
you need an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and you're debt
free before you start talking about
buying
um on a first time home buy i don't
think we don't tell people you have to
put down 20 percent it's just preferable
because if you don't you're going to
have pmi private mortgage insurance
which is going to run you about 75 to
100
per 100 000 borrowed per month
so it turns out to be a lot of money
going to an insurance program that pays
them
the mortgage company in the event you
get foreclosed on that also applies to
first-time home buyers
and home buyer programs
so there are no first-time homebuyer
programs that don't have some kind of
mortgage insurance backing on them
and so it gets to be very very expensive
and the you know the whole premise of a
first-time homebuyer program is that
first-time homebuyers don't do not have
any money and they need to buy a house
anyway well that's a dumb butt idea
and so i stay away from those programs
uh they're really not a big blessing uh
you know and if you don't put down 20
i'm okay with that but put it on a
15-year fixed where the payment's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
and let me tell you what
if you think vancouver washington is an
area you cannot afford to live in under
those guidelines then that means
vancouver washington is an area you
can't afford to live in uh you may not
be able to afford to live in
silicon valley either or in
manhattan island very very expensive
real estate there's a lot of areas
people cannot afford to live in because
they don't make enough money to live
there
i don't think that's true in your case i
think you're
out there looking around at houses and
you just saw some you liked and then you
started crafting this narrative in your
mind that you can't afford that the only
houses that you can afford or are the
only ones you like are the ones that all
they have and that's just not true
so i think you take your time you
continue to learn the real estate market
you get a good down payment in place
it does not have to be 20 20 down but it
does need to be
a 15-year fixed and where the payment is
no more than a fourth of your take-home
pay if you don't do that you're going to
slow
your wealth building dramatically
because you use the wrong set of
assumptions to handle your money
it's going to put you in a pinch
yeah the other thing i would just
encourage you to think about is even if
you want to have more children in the
future you can look at getting a larger
home when you have more cash in the
future you don't have to have your first
home
be the house with all the bedrooms and
the location you want start a little bit
further out of town maybe smaller less
bedrooms and then in a few years that
home value has gone up if you want to
sell and you get more cash saved you'll
have more options you don't have to do
it all right now you don't have to rush
it absolutely
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage bill
and stephanie are with us hey guys how
are you doing great how about you better
than i deserve welcome where do you all
live jacksonville florida oh fun welcome
to nashville and i hear all the way up
here to do a debt-free scream how much
did you pay off
365 000. wow
nice
and how long did this take you 37 months
oh wow kicking it and your range of
income during that time
280 to 450.
wow what do you guys do for a living
i'm membership sales with a freedom boat
club
okay and i'm a pharmacist
very good good for you guys well done
so uh
365 000
dollars what kind of debt was that
uh my student loan
auto loan and a lease
cell phones furniture
and 401k loan and our mortgage oh
look at the weird people
house and everything
wow so how much of the 365 was mortgage
and how much was the pharmacy student
loan
the student loan when we committed to
the plan was about 35 000 but it was 78
at the beginning oh okay so you weren't
i was thinking and our mortgage was
about 265. oh okay so that was the
lion's share actually excellent so you
guys just got 37 months
boom boom once you decide to do it it's
gone huh that's right yeah just like
that all right so i got to hear this
story what in the world got you so fired
up
well we have to go back um so about six
years um ago
you know looking at our marriage was not
in the best of shape and amount of debt
and so
i began my own plan
um
looked at our you know my student loans
and
in nine years had paid off
13 000 towards the principal
and 45 000 in payments
and that was my i'd had monet moment
and so i began tackling the debt in
secret um without my husband's
awareness to alleviate some of the
marital stress
and so
um fast forward to the fall of 2017
we got planted into a local church
through our children and
family who had been praying for us for
years
and our son was saved that winter and um
him and i were baptized
that spring wow wow
yes and so we entered in to
a fast and
a tithing challenge
and so
that's when i had to
basically
confess
to bill that i had been paying off debt
without him knowing and
that didn't go over well
um
so we had to get through that
and
essentially
you know had to ask for forgiveness
and once i got him kind of on board it
was on our way over to nashville
driving over from my grandpa's funeral
that we were listening to your show
and
he agreed to do it with a
with me and so
then we began and a year later
had paid off all of our consumer debt
and established our emergency fund
and
and then began the mortgage
and so
um
let me see here give me one second
what's the church
celebration church oh yeah jacksonville
great yes it's a great church yeah
wonderful yeah very cool they've been a
great family for us she drug me into
that kicking screaming and into the dave
ramsey program kicking his feet
i'm forever forever grateful for it yeah
wow
wow so you both met god as adults in
this process yes we did wow wow that's
amazing
very very cool
okay so
in 2017
um
she comes in and goes i've been secretly
paying off debt
so what was it that uh pissed you off
about that the fact that it was a secret
and you had been deceived because like i
have less debt doesn't make anybody mad
usually yeah i think that the big thing
was i kind of like everybody else i
always think you know you can put that
money into
you know some kind of investment and
make more money than what we were paying
off for our student loans i think that
was the big thing you know it's always
talk about about it at work with a few
dad and nobody likes secrets yeah that's
not cool at all yeah okay that's fair
okay interesting so you're right you're
making the trip into nashville the
radio's on you guys are listening
and uh you're like trapped you can't get
out bill in this car and she's got the
radio dial on there
and so you but something you heard
started clicking what was it
um i think the biggest aha moment for me
was
um she said i want to get rid of my
infinity lease and go buy a used car i
think that's that's what ultimately made
me say okay who's this dave ramsey guy
what the heck yeah
yeah this is he's got way too much
influence here i need to learn about
this character for sure
it was a huge turning point for me yep
it was cars were a big thing ah okay and
he knew that yes they didn't pay
attention so
for you to say that bill's like whoa
this just got real it did yes yeah okay
which for my wife uh the car that she
drive drives i'm a lot more concerned
about it than she is
i can't i'm like you need a better car i
don't get a cat [ __ ] car it's not her
she doesn't cars are not her thing but
you got to know the hot button though oh
yeah that's interesting yep very cool
you guys very cool so your son was how
old when all this happened
when he was eighth grade he was in the
eighth grade so he just went with a
friend to church
so he there was a friend that he knew
went to celebration
and
had been talking to him about it
and so they woke up on sunday morning 8
a.m dressed and ready to go and we had
take we had tried to take him to church
a couple of years prior and it was a
train wreck oh yeah and
but god was in this
and he was leading the way
and what the moment we walked in the
doors we felt like we were home also he
he got up and got dressed and talked you
all into taking him he didn't go with
his friend no the friend just had
invited him yeah the whole family went
yeah both our son and daughter yeah like
we're going to church this these are the
hours
this is the youth program and it was all
based on their friend not but they had
they hadn't been to the youth program at
all they hadn't and and uh when they
were on spring break with my dad and
stepmom they actually picked out a
church you know got online picked out a
church because they always went to
church with them when they went down
south wow found a church that was
similar and got us plugged in wow that
is cool
that's amazing that's so powerful i love
this story
and now no debt house or anything what's
this house worth
well according to zillow
and the current market it's around 500
000.
it is paid for it is it's yours
how does that feel
amazing our neighbors directly across
the street just paid theirs yes wow and
so we come out and cheer each other on i
love it that's awesome well what's the
secret what's the worst thing one
takeaway they're like you got to do this
if you're going to get here
i think the biggest thing is really
doing it together and and getting god
involved in it
that's good
and just being obedient yeah and um
being determined yeah and not giving up
when it gets hard because it does get
hard yeah
it gets hard and it's so worth it look
at you guys now it is on this side of it
it is there is a peace and a contentment
that
is undescribable how's this affected
your marriage
uh it's totally brought us back together
yeah we're doing things as a as a couple
doing things as a family now that's
awesome
yeah that's really cool it's been
amazing you guys are impressive yes i
love it that's man what a three year
journey powerful boom
bomb was dropped on the place it's not
even the same people living in that
house it's completely changed very very
cool very cool and i see our own kim
little sitting out here so you're
plugged into the official baby steps
community oh absolutely very active
okay so you're a big deal in that
community then huh well i think i am
yeah
kim if kim's sitting here if kim's
sitting here you're a big deal because
there's 200 000 300 000 people in there
so if she came out here then you're a
big deal that's fun i love kim that's
cool all right 365 get the kids in what
are their names and ages
bill is 17
and our daughter olivia is 14. all right
365 000 paid off in 37 months making 280
to 450 killing it on the income too
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
man i love that story cool that was
really cool this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day romans 5 4 and
5 patience produces character and
character produces hope and this hope
will never disappoint us
thomas edison said what a man's mind can
create man's character should control
christy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and uh is my
co-host today ramsey personality uh
deanna is with us in jacksonville
florida hi deanna welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you sir
um i'm actually a truck driver i'm 49 my
husband will be 60 in a couple of months
he was my co-driver
but he went out on medical issues two
years ago
and has been being totally disabled
um
we were fortunate enough to have a
long-term disability but we have to
fight for that each month for him to get
that check but he is getting his uh 1200
a month social security disability
and i did my and i make 837
a week bring home and i am on salary and
that is after all the insurances
and
life insurance comes out of my check all
that comes out ahead of that number
okay so um my husband
is not on board with me
um downsizing all the credit and getting
rid of the cards i've been
discovering about a month ago and i had
a conversation with him this morning
his main focus is his everyday i'm only
home six times a year so i don't get to
go home he's at the house
and he mainly focuses on
him and what he's feeling
um and we also have two joint accounts
this check goes into his account
the rest of the stuff goes into my
account and i pay the majority of the
bills
um and his check takes care of his
medications and his food and all that
kind of thing
so you're over the road
yes
yes and i'm i'm on a job that i that i
like they take care of us
they took care of my husband when he had
a problem they worked everything out and
helped us get his long-term disability
initiated so he's getting ssi and
long-term disability
while he meets the quote-unquote
criteria
okay
you guys are hard working
thank you i'm fortunate to have my
brother as my co-driver now
so um but my my credit card debt is uh
twenty thousand seventy seven dollars
we've got a seventy six hundred dollar
motorcycle that my husband really can't
drive anymore but we still owe the debt
on and if i if i turn that back in i
would owe
1500 on it um to the credit union
just to just to get rid of it i did
check on that
and we
um because i married a widower
um
we have been constantly paying off stuff
from his late wife
situation she died of medical issues
um
probably 10 or 12 years ago yeah um
because we got married for eight and uh
we still are paying on a truck that he
thought that they paid for that they
didn't
um
all right let's pull up here for a
second christy
yeah
the the first thing that stands out to
me is
is the fact that y'all are operating in
separate lanes i know there's a lot of
variables there's a lot of debts there's
a lot of bills you got checks coming
from different places but the fact that
you all have separate accounts
and you are responsible for these things
and he's responsible for these things
that's a piece of it that's influencing
how you view
your approach to money more than you
realize it's not just the account that
the money sits in it's the way that you
approach it
and so
putting your money together
into one joint account where all the
income goes in and then you guys sit
down and do
a budget maybe for the first time
together so starting these conversations
and putting money on the same place will
will give you something different to
work from whereas right now when it's
like well this is mine and this is yours
it almost implicitly you all have but
with when he came off the road the thing
that you had in common
was gone
he sits at home you're not home ever
yeah and um he has a he has a set of
problems and a set of money you have a
set of problems and a set of money
and they're completely separated as if
you aren't married
is what you described
so even when you talk to him about being
on board with the plan
the framework that you're operating in
isn't even conducive to that plan i
guess is what i'm saying so i i'm not
saying he'll be super excited about the
plan if you were to combine your
accounts but i think that's an important
first step you're like the ideal
roommate you're never there
well i mean
we're very fortunate to find each other
and we wouldn't trade each other for
anybody i'm not suggesting i'm not
suggesting you divorce i'm telling you
that on a practical
level your day-to-day lives are so
separated
that it's very difficult for you all to
have a common goal
and so what you need to do is step back
from this and set a common goal for the
two of you and the common goal would
include you being taken care of
and him being taken care of so he he's
got this he's dealing with the emotions
of not being able to work and he was a
hard-working dude and he's not able to
do that now and that's emotional for a
guy
uh it's emotional for most people
and um and then you're looking he's
looking at a bike over here he can't
ride anymore and you know you come home
from the road and go your best ideas
sell his bike and that that's that's not
gonna fly real good you know and i'm
sure i'm sure it was not a good
conversation so but the reason for that
is
i know that the reason you're not wrong
to tell him to sell the bike the bike
needs to go i agree
but the the point is is that he's got
this set of needs and once over here and
you've got a completely different set so
we you need to dial back from that and
you guys need to get on phone get on the
zoom call get get back in town and reset
and say okay
you're 65.
when you're 75
and i am 59
where are we going to be
where do we want to be what do we want
our lives to look like
are we still going to be operating the
way we're operating now with careers
whether you're gone all the time at 59
is that what you want to do it's not a
bad thing you just have to decide to do
that on purpose
and where do we want to be with our
money
and then what is the steps
that we need to take with our money to
cause that future out there
to occur well and i think you bring up a
good point because with her husband
going out on disability and i don't know
how recently that happened but the
effects of that
you're still dealing with and so i
wonder when you start to have a
conversation about a common goal even
asking him some questions like
in this transition what is something he
could get excited about and i don't know
what that is what how he spends his time
how is there something he could do a
hobby some something that that within
his abilities in this new reality that
he could get excited about and that will
then flow into the conversation about
money and goals but but in this
transition i'm sure it's been
incredibly hard but when you start
talking about values and dreams and the
future like you're saying dave then then
you know what to do with the money but
but just to zoom out a little bit
because you're right they've got they're
they're running in completely separate
lanes and you got to come together on
what that desired future looks like what
is something you're both looking forward
to and working toward and that brings
you together to work toward it in your
individual ways yeah and and you know
the thing is the umbrella can of what we
want our lives look like should be big
enough to have both of you under yes
yeah you know and you say okay sharon
dave where you all want to be in 10
years okay we're 60 when we're 70 where
do we want to be what do we want our
lives to look like
oh crap we need to make some moves to
cause that to happen to cause that
desired future as henry cloud calls it
that that view of the future that vision
to occur
and if you don't make those moves
because what's happening now is you're
making all your decisions based on what
happens by friday
and what happens by friday for you is
distinctly different than it is for him
yeah very distinctly different
but what hap what you want together for
10 years is probably a lot more similar
than what happens by friday yeah but
then you can both give up something that
happens by friday to get to the
long-term goal because the motorcycle's
not in the 10-year plan yeah you know
it's not but you can come with a new
10-year plan yeah and something else
could be in the 10-year plan right
something else it should be yeah should
be in the 10-year plan
so that that's the way to aim at it and
get it going in that direction hang on
i'll tell you what we're going to do
dana we're going to put you into ramsey
plus for a year and let you and your
husband work on that that's something
you can both do and discuss while you're
on the road both of you can be taking
the class at the same time and that'll
help give you a way to talk through
these issues
hold on we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you